on entend aussi parler d'Agriculture
régénératrice les deux termes ne sont
pas tout à fait synonyme mais certains
piliers reviennent souvent comme
l'intégration des plante pérenne et les
animaux
à tous les jours au sport et puis je
regarde le seul qui me donne de quoi tu
lui as dit quoi
juste à la vigne producteur laitier dans
l'Est de l'Ontario en ce beau jour de
mai c'est 45 vaches se régale de foin
nouveau et une salade de pissenlit frais
mais ils vont manger une 500 lits en
premier à regarder dans 5 minutes
c'est la santé du sol passe par des
racines vivantes celle qu'on trouve sur
sa ferme ne peuvent pas se plaindre
d'être déranger trop souvent là-bas moi
j'ai pas de souvenance je
me souviens pas d'avoir
ça part de 160 hectares est entièrement
en foin un mélange de plante pérenne
comme le trèfle et le loti qui peuvent
survivre pendant des années il y a de
l'importance
c'est bien établie
[Musique]
par rapport aux
on peut voir la profondeur du blé
hôtel ancrage dans le sol permet en
Trotro plan de puiser l'eau plus loin
dans la terre
pour avoir assez de nourriture pour ses
vaches juste elle avait aussi plusieurs
plans différence danse et chant
malgré la sécheresse des derniers était
il n'a jamais manqué de.
encore des photos te particularité du
sol il y a des plantes s'adapte mieux
j'espère ça me donne aussi de voir
qu'est-ce qui pousse le mieux mais ça
pousse bien
des plantes en
monoculture
[Musique]
c'est vache qui folle les champs imite
que l'on pouvait voir sur une bonne
partie de l'Amérique du Nord il y a
quelques centaines d'années dans le
Canada et puis il y avait partout
plante non mais bon c'est la danse
pour maximiser la vie du sol juste à
adopter la technique du pâturage rotatif
se sont divisés en petite parcelle par
des clôture électrique amovible à chaque
midi il les déplace les vaches
reviendront brouter la même parcelle 20
jours plus tard pendant cette pause la
planta le temps de repousser et de faire
croître son système racinaire
aucun engrais chimiques mais tu utilisé
les vaches fertilise elle-même leur
prairie sans tracteur ni pétrole Richard
nutriments la bouche servira de
nourriture aux insectes et aux
micro-organismes du sol la s'ajoute les
restes de plan qui vont se décomposer
qu'est-ce qui est le plus beau dans le
seau c'est quand les résidus comme ça
pour passer l'hiver et moi je me dis
mon solde tout
[Musique]
est
fermé
[Musique]
à toute la société
par exemple de d'une meilleure qualité
de l'eau qui veut dire qu'on aura moins
à dépenser pour le traitement de l'eau
potable
l'agriculture c'est pas seulement pour
devenir des aliments c'est aussi
protéger un écosystème protéger la
biodiversité d'ensemble protéger la
qualité de l'eau protéger la santé
humaine aussi au cours de portage tous
les producteurs interview et nous en
fait par d'emblée de leur prix
occupation quant à la qualité de
l'environnement
appelle Marc sur Richelieu André
Charbonneau s'inquiète de la rivière où
il se baigner quand il était jeune
la métropole c'est pas ta
vie
couvrir les sols et ta façon de réduire
la pollution tous les environnements
jamais calculer la partie
environnementale la pollution
j'ai des enfants, des choses que moi
j'ai fait pour que je pourrais prendre
leur transmettre qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
avec mes grands-parents
je suis à la rivière de vendre des
poissons